foreign
after what feels like 14 years of seeing
nothing but this same screenshot of
Peter and Miles standing next to each
other staring directly at the viewer
like that Meme where you're the weirdest
guy at the party the PlayStation
showcase has delivered onto us the sweet
release of death I mean release the
Gameplay trailer okay let me get the
obligatory complaining out of the way
I'm sure they're going the synthetic
symbiote route for Venom like the
Ultimate Comics and having this thing be
made by Oscorp with hopes of curing
Harry Osborne's goblinism since they do
mention that in the gameplay but I do
kind of hope they go yeah we found this
thing in a crater after a space rock
fell into Central Park It's actually an
alien I guess but they probably won't
they're taking a lot of ideas from the
ultimate cartoon for some reason Tony
Todd is Venom once again one of the
greatest casting choices I've ever damn
heard of but I really hope Harry Osborne
isn't Venom like the ultimate show
because I love Eddie Brock so much but
we'll see what happens but first a word
from our sponsor in 2020 there were over
5 million car crashes that's more than
15 a day and 600 is an hour just back in
December my own dad slid off an icy Road
and broke his hip in four places and the
thought of getting legal help was so
daunting for him
those in an accident can be entitled to
more than you think when something like
that happens it's always good to have
someone in your corner looking out for
your best interest someone like the fine
folks at Morgan and Morgan if you've
been in an accident there are certain
things you need to do make sure you're
okay make sure you get a police report
make sure you contact your insurance and
make sure you get legal representation
so if you're injured and don't know
where to start with Morgan and Morgan
it's so easy Morgan and Morgan have
modernized injury law by making the
process as easy and streamlined as
possible so you can submit a claim in
eight clicks or less no need for you to
visit law offices and sit through timely
consultations you can submit a claim and
have a lawyer review your case and get
started on helping you right away you
can submit your case details sign
contracts upload documents and medical
records all from your cell phone and you
can even text your attorney and legal
team throughout the duration of your
case with Morgan and Morgan you can
submit a claim without ever having to
leave the couch if you're ever injured
in an accident you can check out Morgan
and Morgan for more information go to
forthepeople.com or pound law that's
pound 529 from your cell phone now back
to the video
all that being said holy [__] the
Symbiote looks amazing I love the way
they kept the suit simple and classic at
a distance and the details are only more
apparent up close
it almost looks like the same shape as
the red and blue suit where the more
padded sections are but the parts that
it'd be blue or weird muscular sinew and
it's all creepy to look at it kind of
looks like both textures are inspired by
each movie Venom I've always been a fan
of the idea of the Symbiote looking like
gross skin on top of the wearer so they
nailed the design for me
plus I like the chess logo is so classic
most redesigns ignore the way it
connects from the front to back but I
like the way that it evokes the look of
like a rib cage I think Insomniac
figured out how to do a realistic
symbiote design that avoids the pitfalls
that befell development of Spider-Man 3
where the lack of details and extreme
shininess make it look like a leathery
[__] suit now the only thing they need
to accomplish to make this the greatest
game of all time is ensuring that Venom
doesn't have the creepy pointy toes and
his feet also look like shoes like this
one if they can nail that then Game of
the Year black costume boys
if only Miguel was invited
[Music]
why are you blue doing a black costume
Saga adaptation with Brooklyn Spidey
present sounds like a great idea because
he'll need to go give Peter a taser
noogie to get that suit off and the
conflict will be fun it'd be like a
Spider-Man mirror match boss fight I'm
already stoked by the fact that the map
has been expanded to include Queens I
really hope Brooklyn is in the cards
because that's miles stomping grounds in
the comics and I think it kind of sucks
that they had to stick him in Harlem in
the previous game to avoid making too
many expansions to the open world in a
game that's not a numbered sequel but
he's already become like Harlem
Spider-Man and everyone there loves him
and stuff so maybe that ship has sailed
the gameplay improvements are minor but
interesting it seems that the combat has
really expanded for the black suit and
it gave me a big old blast of nostalgia
for web of Shadows from back in the day
I like this part where he just holds
himself up on one hand and repeatedly
kicks this guy in the nads because that
just seem so excessive someone on
Twitter pointed out to me that that
actually might be a direct parallel to a
combat move from one of the web of
Shadows ports I'm not exactly jazzed
about Brooklyn Spidey becoming Electro
and being able to teleport with
lightning but in the comics he's turning
that Venom blast [__] into a lightsaber
so we're already too far gone sure he's
just electric Spider-Man whatever it's
too late to turn back now I'm hoping The
Swinging feels better in this one less
automated more physics based like the
fortnite web shooters but it seems like
their goal for evolving that mechanic
was the web wings and gliding on air
currents so we'll have to see what it
feels like once I can actually play it
for myself
feel like the marketing for this game
leaning so heavily on praven thus far
has the same kind of bait and switch
that they pulled for Mr negative and Doc
Ock in the first game Craven will
probably be a problem for the first half
of the game then Peter would be all like
you can't escape me I'll Chase through
the ends of the Earth etc etc and
that'll activate the second half of the
story where Venom happens because miles
will have to stop Peter from eating
Craven's face or whatever maybe they'll
rattle Peter into a bloodlust by burying
him alive like last hunt since he's got
the right outfit on granted it's an
alien skin walker suit not the cloth
costume made for him to let the goth
consume him in one swath by the girl
with whom he had relationships on a
rooftop instead of a room but I don't
know if they'd go for a Craven's last
hunt adaptation since it's pretty dark
could just be wishful thinking on my
part but I'd enjoy to enjoy this not
like the movies are doing that you think
Aaron Taylor Johnson is going to shoot
himself in the face no glad to see the
lizard is growing into a giant spiky
super monster again for black suit
Spider-Man to fight while Craven hunts
them both
man it's like 2007 all over again I'm
going to die I'm happy with everything
I've seen of the gameplay so far and I
hope the costume selection includes all
the previous ones and a new selection of
various symbiote reskins for Peter like
even more comic accurate poison other
thing also called Poison Ray me black
suit go down swinging suit with the dumb
sunglasses eyes I don't know why he has
that maybe Spider Carnage if you really
want to push it I do wonder how
alternate costumes will be handled as
the series goes long the last main game
was five years ago in the gaps in
development along with the leaps and
gaming technology are going to force
them to update some of the models as
they go along I hope they don't have to
completely redo all the alternate skins
like the Arkham games did because that
just sounds like a giant pain in the ass
anime force them to leave out some of
the previous ones for budgetary reasons
but I also love the idea of them keeping
all of them and just having this massive
library of like 60 fully unique costumes
per character once they get to the third
game we'll have to see what their plan
is for that you know I haven't done a
gutter space in a while and a couple of
other cool things came out that I want
to talk about do you mind if I cover
some of that too even if it's older news
I better not check the video engagement
and see 80 percent of viewers clicked
off when I started talking about
Transformers because I really want to
talk about Transformers okay let me
start by saying I don't give a [__]
about wheel Jack or what he looks like
even if they decide to make him a giant
robot Steve Urkel I'm glad this movie
has the stones to just give us Unicron
and be a sort of spiritual Transformer
six except now Unicron isn't the Earth's
core like that Transformers Prime Arc
just a big orange Galactus rip-off ball
I love Planet eating scary Moon sized
Transformer he was the final boss of the
PS2 game and he was in all the dubbed
anime shows on Cartoon Network I was
worried this could be some dumbass we
gotta build him up for multiple movies
before we actually fight him thing like
Thanos back in the 80s they introduced
him at the beginning of the film built
them up throughout the middle of it and
then they fought him at the end and it
was epic the MCU has riled everyone up
into thinking movies need to spread out
every single storyline across several
years when sometimes it's most effective
and exciting to just get it all done in
two hours I will say though I have mixed
feelings on the final shot of this
trailer
I will praise it for the clarity of
action its well-defined character
designs and a lot of his really
fantastic animation but it looks like
the same big gray sludge desert
Dimension from endgame I think
screenwriters keep placing the biggest
action scenes in empty Fields like Goku
to avoid Man of Steel criticisms of
property damage
but the answer is to just show the
heroes you know heroically saving people
during the fight reminds us what they're
fighting for and it heightens the stakes
actually this is a hideously poorly
defined CGI piece of terrain this is a
Beast Wars movie I've seen a lot of
discourse about this versus the Bay
versus action scenes and I'd like to
give my two cents on that debate that no
one cares about Bayes action scenes had
the benefit of filming in real locations
instead of CG planes and mixed practical
elements with animated ones in very
believable ways to me a long take in
live action will always be more
impressive than one rendered in 3D
because you have to coordinate that much
harder to make sure every element of the
scene runs smoothly and it takes a lot
of rehearsal and planning in case
something unexpected forces a full
retake a long uncut shot in complete CG
still takes so much work to pull off
with animation and compositing but the
Rogue elements aren't really a factor
when you can edit and control every
asset on the screen and tweak the timing
and movement however you want Michael
Bay could blend both of these processes
together in really believable and
interesting ways and continues to do so
in some of his more recent work but I
would absolutely never say they were
more colorful movies sorry Mauricio
you're wrong actually the guy liked the
film at Golden hour and that made some
pretty shots but between the completely
over-the-top lens flare and almost
exclusively silver Decepticons the
orange glow of the Setting Sun didn't
really help make the action scenes more
memorable and clear plus you got that
[__] with the hyperactive fast-cutting
focal point changing in every shot look
here no there no here no over there and
the aspect ratio changing like 10 times
a minute and some of the later ones and
the camera just never sitting still and
always being at a Dutch angle like the
tripod was too short on one side it was
on a skateboard rolling down an 85
degree angled Hill just because rise of
the Beast looks muddy like most big
budget movies lately let's not revise
history and pretend this stuff was
considerably better or something
film Twitter has melted my brain maybe
this is all obvious to normal people but
I feel like I need to remind a subset of
you that have gone completely insane
Revenge of the Fallen is not a bold
challenging film with complex moral
messages crafted by an Artur director
with a brilliant Vision these movies are
goofy mindless schlock with needlessly
Savage and brutal Heroes repetitive
plots and a lot of over-the-top racist
caricatures that are the butt of the
joke was cracking little [__] my
first glutenant
designation Jazz this looks like a cool
place to kick it
and all the Transformers penis stuff his
name's wheelie say my name say my name
[Applause]
I've come cause I'm coming it is time
to come let them come I am coming Prime
coming I watched it when I was eight
years old too man I promise it's not
underrated you gotta let it go you have
to wake up the accident was 10 months
ago your family misses you and while
we're revising history and ignoring
reality Transformers 1 will apparently
be the first animated Transformers movie
in theaters
Optimus Prime died for nothing you've
heard me get annoyed at this before but
it Bears repeating Hollywood's attitude
towards professional voice actors and
animation and games is completely
backwards and disrespectful I'm not
irritated with a voice cast because I
hate change and want Peter Cullen to be
Optimist forever in all honesty he's not
even my favorite Prime voice actor Gary
chalk is hey go watch that video by the
way I've always been open to other
voices for the Transformers characters
David K is great as a young Optimist
Gary chalk is a legend and even Alan
Tudyk does a solid job but what kind of
voice work has Chris Hemsworth done
the Thor tie-in game an episode of what
if really would have preferred someone
with more experience and the same goes
for the rest of this cast this isn't to
say that Screen Actors have historically
never made the transition to voice
acting successfully many Screen Actors
have proven in the past that they can
build a really respectable career in
voice performances with the right
training people like JK Simmons Ron
Perlman Dietrich Bader Christian Shaw
Pamela adlin Clancy Brown Mark Hamill
Keith David Mila Kunis and sometimes you
have Screen Actors that just naturally
have exaggerated voices that sound like
cartoon characters already like Jack
Black Charlie Day Jim Carrey Jason
monsoukas Patrick Warburton John Mulaney
and Alan Tudyk Alan tudik especially has
proven in a lot of DC projects over the
last decade that he's got the chops in
good range
so I didn't bad nigh at him getting cast
for Earth Spark
but like Scarlett Johansson is the main
female lead have you heard her voice
she's already so stoic and understated
barring sound wave these guys aren't
actually supposed to sound robotic I
just don't have much confidence in some
of these picks for the characters given
their track records maybe key will be
okay I couldn't really tell it was him
as toad in the Mario movie Lawrence
Fishburne will do all right for sure but
the rest
sometimes you can pull a miracle with a
great voice director like they did for
invincible to get the celebrity voice
cast to actually sound like they give a
[__]
but if they don't have that this movie
runs the risk of having the most bored
sounding Transformer since the rooster
teeth shows Butch a non-union scabs on
the other side of the 80s action figure
cartoon coin the mutant Mayhem trailer
has me seriously impressed with its main
cast for the four turtles they went out
of their way to find actual experienced
voice actors with multiple years on the
job who are also real teenagers look Leo
is one of them funny Gumball kids
instead of some weird nonsense like Tom
Holland and Timothy chalamet mumbling
lines to each other while audibly
texting between takes to plan their
sleepover Timothy's gonna bring the
nachos and Tom's gonna get the root beer
floats and Zendaya's sleeping upstairs
alone well that's all the new stuff I
can think about for now unless a lot of
new stuff gets announced soon you might
see a long gap before the next gutter
space but rest assured we're still doing
them as long as there's more stuff for
me to speculate on
stay tuned for extreme heartbreak
[Music]
foreign